e
[Música]
quem diria que aquela mulher tímida e
introvertida seria a vencedora do que
seja doce
escolhida entre 1.900 pessoas
como empreendedor a Popular ganhando
quinto lugar
palestrantes no evento ela pode que é
uma maior evento de empreendedorismo
feminino do Brasil sediado pelo Google
teria várias histórias para contar e
Hoje estarei aqui o
empreendedorismo é aquilo que a vida nos
dá presente e meia necessidade ou a
decisão daquele que optem revolucionar o
caminho e reflita comigo quantas pessoas
próximas à você abriram o próprio
negócio e quantas optar em permanecer
pelo mesmo caminho Tradicional
em 2002 foi o que a vida me apresentou
quando eu me vi
desempregada Recém casada e mãe de Uma
Criança com 8 meses Aliás a maternidade
nos transforma em mães mas ao mesmo
tempo invisíveis em capacitados aos
olhos de muitos quando decidir entender
eu queria apenas transformar o meu
trabalho em dinheiro fui trabalhar com o
chocolate aproveitando a Páscoa que é um
período de boas vendas alto faturamento
e bons lucros e assim foram durante 11
anos no período de 2002 A 2013 onde tive
grandes conquistas materiais a minha
casa por exemplo e pessoais cursos
graduação viagens qualidade de bom e
você há quanto tempo vive no piloto
automático apenas cumprindo a sua rotina
e desvalorizando as suas conquistas
porque não priorize foca em algo que
possa lhe render bons frutos e
satisfação
Quando foi a última vez que você
participou
planejou e cumprir Um grande projeto
medo tive muitos indecisões na mesma
proporção do medo mas antes que me
paralisassem decidi caminhar a tomada de
decisão batia na minha porta
decidir recomeçar Saindo da Zona de
conforto e por minha conta e risco me
demitir de um trabalho CLT onde eu
estava 2 anos a passo dado várias coisas
precisavam ser reformulados e uma delas
era sair da Visão da mulher que só fazia
doces para status de empresa em 8 anos
no período de 2013 a2021 o empreender
por necessidade se tornou empreender por
escolha e costumo dizer que a definição
distinta para cada uma delas o
empreender por necessidade não tem
escolha é fazer uma faxina lavar uma
roupa para fora vender algum produto
enfim gerar uma renda rápida para suprir
todas as necessidades
o empreender por escolha é definida a
base de muita reflexão e planejamento e
na maioria das vezes somos obrigados a
deixar alguma coisa para trás um serviço
CLT por exemplo
em desistir só é substituído por para
quê que eu fui inventar isso mas se você
parar para analisar toda a trajetória
verá grandes transformações
Quanto tempo mais vai esperar para que
algo excepcional aconteça na sua vida
finalizando que você tomou ou vai tomar
a decisão assertivo a verdade que essa
decisão é somente sua mas eu posso
assegurar que coisas recepcionar é só
acontece quando estamos caminhando
acertando errando e produzindo
vamos começa de onde você está saindo da
sua zona de conforto
uso que você tem coragem e força de
vontade são primordiais se brinde Não dê
ouvidos a quem não conhece a sua
história e quem nunca construiu nada e
voa em direção aos seus sonhos e se é
muito feliz e